I'm live streaming live this Monday from
8:15 to 1000 p.m. doing straight Q&A old
tea with Gary ve going to call some of
you while I'm on
streaming Lincoln bio 8:15 to10 this
Monday on
Twitch but that's not what this video is
about this video is about Lincoln bio it
is about that I want to see all of you
there but this is also about that I've
been quietly building up live streaming
from the office kind of work with me
behind the scenes content and in general
I think 2024 is the year that a lot of
you that are deep social media content
need to start getting deep live
streaming Tik Tok live is incredible
because it gets you discoverability when
you're on it shows up in streams and
more people discover you which is
different than Instagram where you go on
and pings your audience and then the
viewership declines Tik Tok grows but
twitch obviously the master platform for
this and much like Tik Tok where early
on it was 14-year-old girls and then you
know it evolved into everybody or
Facebook which it was college kids and
then involved into everybody twitch has
been for really incredible Gamers
streamers uh people that are
professional streamers entertainers but
I think over time it's going to be for
everyone live streaming for everyone and
I'm doing the entrepreneurial business
operator version of it but this Monday a
special show where I'm just doing Q&A I
can't wait to see all of you who's in
and who realizes live streaming is the
next step on their entrepreneurial and
business
Journey